THE FIVE.
♪
>> Greg: PRESIDENT BIDEN FINALLY
ADDRESSING THE SUPPLY CHAIN JAM
THAT THREATENS TO ROYAL, YES,
ROYAL THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
AND ALSO JESSE, JR.'S CHRISTMAS
GIFT.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
COMES AMID A SLEW OF BAD
HEADLINES SHOWING JOE'S MET MORE
FA SUS INTO JIMMY CART IS IS
ALMOST COMPLETE.
THEY'RE QUITTING JOBS AT A
RECORD PACE, INFLATION SURGING
MORE THAN EXPECTED IN SEPTEMBER
WITH CONSUMERS PAYING 5.4% MORE
FOR GOODS COMPARED TO LAST YEAR.
AND THE WHITE HOUSE IS WARNING
SHOPPERS THEIR STOCKINGS ARE
GOING TO LOOK EMPTY.
NOT MINE.
OUTRIGHT SAYING THERE WILL BE
THINGS THAT PEOPLE CAN'T GET.
HERE'S THE PRESIDENT.
>> THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES
ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT IT'S GOING
TO BEGIN OPERATING 24 HOURS A
DAY, SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE A GAME CHANGER.
FED-EX AND UPS, TWO OF OUR
NATION'S BIGGEST FREIGHT MORES
ARE COMMITTING TODAY TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF GOODS THEY'RE MOVING
AT NIGHT AND NOW WE NEED THE
REST OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR CHAIN
TO STEP UP AS WELL.
THIS IS NOT CALLED A SUPPLY
CHAIN FOR NOTHING.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE GET
THE INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN PASSED.
WE'VE SEEN THE COST OF INACTION
IN THE PANDEMIC, IN THE DELAYS.
THE CONGESTION THAT AFFECT EVERY
AMERICAN.
>> Greg: IT'S UP TO YOU NOW TO
STEP UP.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT'S IN
CHARGE OF THE POSTAL SERVICE
SAYING EARLIER THAT THEY AREN'T
ACTUALLY THE POSTAL SERVICE.
>> CAN THIS ADMINISTRATION
GUARANTEE THAT HOLIDAY PACKAGES
WILL ARRIVE ON TIME.
>> WE ARE NOT THE POSTAL SERVICE
OR UPS OR FED-EX.
WE CANNOT GUARANTY.
WHAT WE CAN DO IS USE EVERY
LEVER AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DISPOSAL TO REDUCE DELAYS TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
BOTTLE NEXT IN THE SYSTEM.
>> Greg: NO WONDER THE
PRESIDENT'S POPULARITY IS
SINKING FASTER THAN HUNTER'S
NOSE IN A MOUND OF FINE BA
LIVEIAN FLAKE.
>> IT'S A COCAINE JOKE.
>> NO, IT'S A CHOCOLATE BAR.
>> Greg: SO DANA WHEN YOU HEAR
ABOUT, IT ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO
NOW IT'S UP TO US.
>> Dana: YES.
>> Greg: THE GOVERNMENT, IT'S
NOT REALLY OUR FAULT.
>> Dana: THEY BUILD IT AS IF THE
PRESIDENT'S GOING TO TAKE ACTION
AS IF YOU ARE THE PROBLEM.
DO YOU THINK THERE ARE RETAILERS
OR BUSINESSES IN AMERICA WHO
DON'T WANT TO SELL STUFF?
OF COURSE THEY DO.
DO YOU THINK THE TRUCK DRIVERS
DON'T WANT TO GET PAID?
THE PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN BUILDING
FOR A LONG TIME.
IT TAKES ABOUT SIX MONTHS FOR
ONE OF THESE THINGS.
SO JESSE JR. MIGHT GET HIS GIFT
ON EASTER AT THIS RATE AND, YOU
KNOW --
>> Greg: HE WON'T CARE.
>> Dana: BE GRATEFUL.
I ALSO BELIEVE WE COULD HAVE A
SEGMENT ON THE FIVE LEADING WITH
A DRAMATIC INTERPRETATION THE
CHIEF OF STAFF RETWEETS AND
TWEETS ABOUT HOW GREAT IT IS
THAT UNEMPLOYMENT'S AT 5% AND
THIS IS GREAT BECAUSE NOW PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO GET PAID MORE TO DO
THINGS.
OKAY, HOWEVER, EMPLOYERS SPENT
THE LAST SIX MONTHS COMPETING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT, THE
BENEFITS FOR THE WORKERS.
THEY REDUCED THEIR BUSINESSES.
THEY CUT THEIR HOURS.
THEY SERVED FEWER CUSTOMERS.
YOU THINK THAT THEY DON'T
WANT -- OF COURSE THEY DO.
AND MAYBE THERE ARE STRUCTURAL
THINGS THAT HAPPENED IN THE
ECONOMY BUT WHAT ALSO HAS
HAPPENED IS THE INFLATION.
SO CNBC CALLED IT TODAY A TWO
PERCENT PAY CUT FOR PEOPLE IN
AMERICA.
SO YOU CAN PAY MORE BUT THAT
MEANS THAT PEOPLE ARE ALSO
PAYING MORE AT THE GROCERY
STORE, AT THE PUMP.
IT WILL BE A DARK HOLIDAY
SEASON.
I SAW ONE FUNNY CARTOON WITH
SANTA TELLING A LITTLE KID,
SORRY, WE'RE ALSO OUT OF COAL.
>> Greg: YOU BRING UP A GREAT
POINT.
JUDGE, COAL THAT CREATES ENERGY,
THE DEMS ARE SAYING, THEY'RE
PROMISING EVERYTHING IS GOING TO
GET TO EVERY -- HOW DOES THIS
STUFF GET MOVED?
IT'S FUEL.
IT'S FUEL, WHICH IS LIKE --
>> EXACTLY.
>> Greg: SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING
MAYBE IS A PREP ANYTHINGS OR A
FORESHADOWING OF WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THIS IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE
GETTING USED TO.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
GET USED TO THE FACT YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET ANYTHING
YOU USED TO GET BECAUSE WE'RE
NOW PART OF THIS NEW CLIMATE
CHANGE, GREEN DEAL, YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE ANYTHING.
BUT WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THIS STORY
THE MOST IS THE ABILITY OF THE
WHITE HOUSE TO DEFLECT.
YOU KNOW, WHILE INFLATION IS
RISING, WAGE EARNERS AREN'T
MAKING MORE MONEY, MORE PEOPLE
ARE QUITTING BECAUSE THEY CAN
MAKE MORE MONEY STAYING AT HOME.
THIS IS ALL THE WHITE HOUSE'S
PROBLEM AND DONALD TRUMP
PREDICTED THIS LAST YEAR.
HE SAID, THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND, BY THE WAY, WHO'S THE
GENIUS WHO JUST FIGURED OUT, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN GET MORE DONE IF WE
WORK SEVEN DAYS A WEEK, 24/7.
ARE YOU STUPID?
I MEAN, REALLY.
SO THIS IS WHAT I THINK THE
PROBLEM IS.
I THINK PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO,
WOULD, THEY'RE NOT GETTING PAID
TO WORK.
THEY THINK THAT THERE'S A
BENEFIT AT THE END IF THEY DON'T
WORK, AND THE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
WORK CAN'T GET THE JOBS THAT
THEY WANT TO GET.
>> Greg: GERALDO I WENT AND
CALLED BMW.
SEEMS THAT YOUR MINI WILL NOT BE
ARRIVING FOR AT LEAST ANOTHER
SEVEN MONTHS.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT IT UP,
BECAUSE MY 16 YEAR OLD IS
DRIVING, I'M VERY NERVOUS ABOUT
THAT BUT SHE'S EXCELLENT.
HERE'S MY POINT AND I THINK THIS
HELPS SOLVE THIS WHOLE DILEMMA.
UNIONS HAVE TO LISTEN TO WHAT
I'M ABOUT TO SAY.
COME ON BOARD.
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO BE 21 YEARS
OF AGE TO DRIVE THESE BIG RIGS?
WHY NOT 18?
WHY NOT ON HE-THE HARDEST THING
TO DO IS EMPLOY INNER CITY KIDS
FROM 18 TO 21.
THEY GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THEM LEGAL
UNTIL THEY CAN BECOME A MEMBER
OF THE POLICE FORCE OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
18-21 LET THEM BE OUR DRIVERS.
THEY CAN PASS THESE TESTS.
IT ENORMOUSLY INCREASESES THE
POOL OF AVAILABLE DRIVERS AND
THAT I SUBMIT, IT'S NOT THE
SHIPS, IT'S THE TRUCKS.
THAT'S WHY THOSE CONTAINERS ARE
SITTING ON THOSE DOCKS AND
THERE'S NO 1 TO DRIVE THEM.
LET THE KIDS DO IT.
>> THAT WAS ON AMERICA'S NEWS
ROOM THIS MORNING.
>> IT WAS?
>> HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTEN A
PROFESSOR ON.
HE'S 18 YEARS OLD AND SAID I
THINK I CAN HAVE A CAREER.
>> GREAT.
>> AREN'T THEY TALKING ABOUT
RELAXING THE REQUIREMENTS OF
BEING A COMMERCIAL TRUCK DRIVER.
THEY SHOULD PROBABLY GET TO
THAT.
>> Greg: I COULD NEVER DRIVE A
TRUCK.
>> Dana: IT'S HARD TO REACH THE
PEDAL.
>> THE MEXICANS ARE GREAT
DRIVERS.
I JUST CAME BACK FROM MEXICO,
THEY'RE EVERYWHERE.
GIVE TEMPORARY VISAS UNTIL MY
18-21 PLAN COMES INTO EFFECT,
GIVE THE MEXICAN DRIVERS
TEMPORARY, UNDERLINE TEMPORARY
VISAS AND LET THEM DRIVE
DOMESTICALLY IN THE UNITED
STATES TO HELP.
>> Greg: YOU DID NOT SAY
MEXICANS ARE GREAT DRIVERS.
THEY'RE BRINGING THE BEST
DRIVERS.
>> Dana: CAN BE TRUE THAT THEY
ARE GREAT DRIVERS.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> JESSE: IT'S NOT JUST THE
TRUCK DRIVERS, LOOK AROUND THE
TABLE.
WHERE'S THIS MADE?
WHERE'S THIS MADE.
>> CHINA, CHINA, CHINA, CHINA.
>> JESSE: EVERYTHING AROUND HERE
IS MADE IN CHINA.
WHOSE FAULT IS THAT?
JOE BIDEN AND HIS BUDDY AFTER
THE COLD WAR THEY MADE SURE THEY
BROUGHT ALL THIS FROM CHINA AND
ASIAN.
SO NOW OUR DESTINY IS PART OF
THEIR DESTINY.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A PANDEMIC
AND A SUPPLY CHAIN PROBLEM AND
WHY JESSE JR. ISN'T GOING TO GET
ANYTHING FROM CHRISTMAS.
SORRY, IT'S CHINA'S FAULT AND
JOE BIDEN'S FAULT.
>> Greg: HAVE YOU TALKED TO HIM
ABOUT THIS?
>> JESSE: NO.
I HOPE HE'S NOT WATCHING FOR
MANY, MANY REASONS.
AND JOE BIDEN HAD A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS, AFTER
THE LAB LEAK HE COULD HAVE BEEN
INAUGURATED AND SAID GUYS WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE YOU PAY THE PRICE,
INCENTIVIZE ALL THESE COMPANIES
TO REMOVE THESE FACTORIES, BRING
THEM TO THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE,
EVEN IF THEY'RE IN OUR
HEMISPHERE, THE SHIPPING LANES
ARE MUCH EASIER TO GO SOUTH TO
NORTH.
BUT, NO, NO, NO.
IMAGINE THE SUPPLY CHAIN PROBLEM
IF TAYWAN POLICE UP OR CHINESE
REAL ESTATE BLOWS UP.
IT'S GOING TO BE A MESS.
YOU'RE GOING TO ORDER STUFF OFF
AMAZON AND IT WON'T GET HERE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BUILD
YOUR OWN FURNITURE.
YOU WANT TO SIT IN FURNITURE I
BUILT?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
SO HE COMES OUT TODAY AND SAYS
I'M GOING TO CALL COMPANIES SO
THEY CAN HIRE MORE DRIVERS AND
IN THE SAME SENSE HE GOES, WE
NEED TO GO GREEN.
MORE TRUCKERS, MAKE THIS A GREEN
ECONOMY, DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
I COULD IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP
IF THIS HAPPENED UNDER HIS
WATCH, HE WOULD HAVE HAD IN THE
OVAL, HE WOULD HAVE HAD THE HEAD
OF THE TRUCKING UNION GUY, HE
WOULD HAVE HAD THE SHIPPING MAG
NATES THERE AND HE WOULD HAVE
HAD A WHOLE CONVERSATION, GOT A
CON SEN AND SAID THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO.
>> Greg: IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
GREAT, SAY YOUR NAME, INTRODUCE
YOURSELF.
>> JESSE: REMEMBER WHAT WE USED
TO DO?
RIGHT.
AND NOW JOE SAID HE CALLED
SOMEONE.
>> Dana: I JUST WANT TO MENTION
ONE OTHER THING.
THE PRESIDENT HASN'T NOT HAD